i'm really excited to welcome murray
hebert to today's brownback which will
be the last one of the semester we've
had a very dynamic
session of brownbacks this semester
with people from all over the world
zooming in
murray is currently a senior associate
of the southeast asia program
at the center for strategic and
international studies csis in washington
d.c
and he has recently completed a book
about china's involvement in southeast
asia
which we will be hearing about today i'm
especially excited to have him here
today because
it brings me back to my first year in
graduate school
at cornell when i was just beginning my
academic study of vietnam
i've been working in vietnam for over 20
years now but back then
in the croc library at cornell his book
chasing the tigers a portrait of the new
vietnam
which was published in 1996 built from
his first-hand observations in the early
1990s
when he was based in hanoi and writing
for the far eastern
economic review which at that time those
of you who've been studying
southeast asia for a long time was one
of the most important sources of serious
journalism for all of southeast asia and
other parts of asia as well
some of you probably remember our own
recently retired colleague nyan chanda
who also worked for the far eastern
economic review
and like nion murray hebert was part of
an important
cohort of embedded journalists who were
offering on-the-ground reporting of
vietnam
during important post-war periods and
his vietnam books
are especially important for the
portraits they offer of the early 1990s
when some of the changes associated with
vietnam's doing
period and the post-socialist reforms
were beginning to come into effect and
it was a time when
society of vietnam was rapidly
transforming economically
politically and socially and murray
hebert was one of the few people who was
really on the ground writing about all
those transformations
it's been more than 20 years since i
first read that book in cornell's
library
and i'm really eager to be able to meet
murray for the first time
and to hear what he has to say about
china's involvement in southeast asia
so please join me in welcoming murray
hebert to our zoom edition brown bag
series
his talk today like his newly published
book
is entitled under beijing's shadow
southeast asia's china challenge
murray great uh thanks a lot for that uh
kind introduction eric and
you've really flashed me back to the old
days
um those were the days actually in ins
and in journalism in southeast asia
because or a lot of parts of asia
because you
foreign journalists were there was quite
a few of them and we had quite a few
outlets
uh in the far eastern economic review i
was lucky to be
working for them and they yeah they
provided a lot of the early
early uh reporting that was coming out
of
countries like vietnam that was going
through a transition
um now of course the media has
has really shrunk down the number of
journalists the far eastern economic
review
no longer exists it died in 2004 it
wasn't
owned by dow jones that really didn't
feel like they could carry it anymore
when advertising was getting hammered
yeah so this uh as my new book is
about like you said how how southeast
asia is responding to china's rise
so what i'll do is i'll try to give uh
some uh maybe in about half our time
here give a
overview of of the key themes of the
book i'll try to
intersperse uh examples from different
countries
uh because uh one thing that is
um quite uh quite clear when you start
doing this research and writing
is that uh southeast asian countries are
all responding to china
very differently depending on how big
they are how close they are to china
their politics uh
those kinds of dynamics there and and
their history with china is also very
important
um but it's fair to say that all the
countries really do
respond to china see china as a
both a challenge and an opportunity
the opportunity is that they think china
is going to yank them up by their
bootstraps
and help their economies develop which
is in fact true i
all the countries uh have benefited
immensely
uh and then the the uh challenge is a
considerable concern about what it means
for their
sovereignty going forward especially the
countries on the border
of china which is myanmar laos and and
vietnam
uh so i i go through i i do it country
by country
uh that's not always the most creative
way to do it but
but what you try to go with themes and
it really
doesn't work because the themes are so
different
uh the pro the the issues you need to
cover in each country is so different
but i i do look at at china's different
uh tools that it brings it brings
salt power including economic
cooperation
cultural cultural exchanges uh
mandarin language training more hard
power
that includes threats in the south china
sea economic pressures on countries that
don't do what china wants
uh and as well as military sales and
military exchanges
and sometimes it even gets into
considerably sharper power like
especially dealing with its
communist neighbor uh biggest communist
neighbor immediately to the south
vietnam
uh with which it has had considerable
disputes
uh uh for decades but really
in in the recent years a lot of pressure
on vietnam's
oil and gas exploration i'll get into
that
um later the uh
um economic cooperation as i mentioned
has really exploded
uh china's two-way trade with the 10
countries of southeast asia and country
southeast asia was 60 billion
uh last year excuse me 600
billion last year which is double
the us trade figures with the region and
it's
up tremendously uh uh since
since uh uh china started opening up in
in the late 70s and early 80s a lot of
the
economic benefit also comes from from
tourism
uh it's hard to get accurate numbers but
there were an estimated
60 million
chinese tourists that visited the
southeast asian countries last year
that's obviously going to be down
tremendously this year because of kova
the numbers will be really small and it
really is hurting countries
that rely on tourism like like thailand
for example
um and then the other big um
big way that uh countries look to china
is the belt and road initiative this is
china's big uh signature
uh economic development uh project that
that uh it it's looking to build
globally railroads and
dams and highways and bridges and power
stations and
you name it they even include include
free trade agreements or trade
agreements in in the belton road
but china has really had trouble this
it's had real difficulties getting this
thing off the road
off off the ground um the
uh uh every
every uh uh situation is
is really complex even tiny laos that
agreed to build a railroad
negotiated for five years you wouldn't
have thought that that they would be
able to stand up to china for five years
but they were negotiating over the
interest rates and how much laos would
contribute to
china starts by wanting you you to pay
for your whole project yourself
um and laos that would have been half
their gdp
uh and so they really fought back they
china also wants land on both sides of
the railroad so that they can
you know their their their business
people can make money
um and finally they did agree uh
but and the railroad is now cranking
along
it it will be finished it was to be
finished at the end of next year but it
might
slip into 2022 because of the slowdown
by
brother resulting from covet thailand
which needs to build the next railroad
so this thing keeps moving
back all the way from kunming to to
singapore
has been negotiating since 2014
when when china thought with the coup
government the uh
the pr prayut government would be able
that they would be
really interested in doing this because
they were getting
a lot of isolation they were getting
some sanctions and
other pressure from the us and the
european union
uh but they but the thais and the
chinese have had
over 30 rounds of um of
talks and they still haven't agreed and
they're the
the negotiations are over slightly more
complicated issues than they were in
laos
uh that the thais say well we don't need
your money
chinese money is not cheap they start
usually at a
from the x exam bank the export import
bank or the china development bank
usually start around four and a half
percent
uh these are both money making
institutions uh they're not
aid organizations let's say like u.s
exam
or japanese exam um and
uh the so the thai
said well we don't need that we don't
need money we can get money in the
international market
they also said we don't need your
engineers uh china likes to send lots of
workers
we don't need your engineers we got a
lot of engineers of our own
and we don't necessarily want your
technology
we uh you know there's german and
there's japanese and other technology
and so they're still fussing around over
this i don't know what's going
to happen they did finally agree on
building a 2.5
kilometer get this 2.5 kilometers out of
several hundred kilometers as a pilot
project
um and then in indonesia they also build
a railroad but it's the high-speed train
from jakarta to bandong
it's about 150 kilometers uh
there the thing was is also moving
slowly since 2015 when it was
uh agreed upon uh
partially because of the difficulties
that china
and chinese companies and their their
indonesian partners have in getting land
so really absolutely every place
uh and then actually there's myanmar is
also another interesting example
um you would think that after they uh
myanmar the
aung san tsuji government was involved
in kicking out the rohingya
in 2017 and early 2018
resulted in a lot of isolation and
from the west you would think they would
want to move ahead with china but
it's china has been negotiating over the
chukwu dam which is
on on the uh western side of
myanmar on the indian ocean china would
has two pipelines and oil and a gas
pipeline leading there already but they
want to also build uh
a port and one to a big port that
some people suspect has dual use meaning
civilian and military
and uh and uh uh
the the myanmar has held them off and
finally they have renegotiated
repeatedly
and scaled it back and
still they have not no work has started
on it
the same is true with the uh with the
myanmar the china myanmar economic
corridor
which is to lead from kunming down to to
several
major cities in in myanmar um
and we include roads and railroads
uh and xi jinping uh the chinese leader
has
was there two years ago and really put a
lot of pressure on them to get going
nothing happened they had elections a
few weeks ago
and uh she just called aung sang tsuchi
again this week and said you got to get
cranking
but myanmar really is almost as
as nationalistic as the vietnamese and
so
it is it is tough uh for china to
to get much going there as well we don't
know exactly how much
china has invested in the belton road in
in southeast asia
but there's a consulting company in
washington called
rwr associates and they estimate the
number at about 200 million
in the five years after 2013 but having
visited the countries and visited a lot
of projects
in the two years uh 2018-19 that i was
writing the book
i i really think that number is pretty
high
some projects also get bogged down in so
i'm spending a lot of time on this but
this is really a signature
china chinese project and it's good to
know
that despite the coverage you get in the
chinese
media that this thing is not cranking
along by any means
um they uh the previous prime minister
uh of of malaysia najib brazak
signed an agreement to build the east
coast rail link but he was defeated in
an election
in may of 2018 and his successor
to was mahathir mohamad 2.0 he came back
after
after once running the country for 20
years and then leaving for a while
he was re-elected and he put a stop to
it just because of
he thought china had overcharged he
thought that there was a lot of
kickbacks going to najib and to najib's
very distressed state investment company
known as
one development one malaysia development
perhaps
or one one mdb
and uh they eventually china agreed
to negotiate but but the their
the uh trial najib has been uh
is still under trial for some of the
corruption
that that will spin off of this and
other
this project and in others uh that china
was involved in or were domestic
projects
and we could go on and in that vein but
i'm gonna
uh get going here on some other uh some
other themes
um the other i should say just one more
thing if you push
back as the lao proved as malaysia
approved
if you push back against projects even
once they're going
you can get china to renegotiate they
have been
somewhat reasonable and showing
flexibility and willingness to
compromise
um for some countries uh cooperating too
much
with china is is uh
very controversial domestically you and
last year in 2019 joko widodo or
jokowi as he's known for short was
running again for
president of indonesia and he has relied
a lot on china for infrastructure
projects
beyond the one that i mentioned to the
high-speed rail from jakarta to bandung
and uh he got a lot of criticisms from
his
his challengers uh for depending too
much
on china and i i may i'll get get back
to indonesia
indonesia has a unique set of situations
of attitudes toward toward china dating
back to 1965 when
china has been accused of being involved
in in supporting a coup against socar
now
i was then the president the other area
in which
china is very involved and this is
probably much more successful
is in the so-called digital silk road uh
so that's the
digital economy uh invest is china is
very active in investing in unicorns the
company startups over at worth over a
billion dollars e-commerce
various e-payment schemes huawei
in southeast asia is very active in 5g
you may remember that
president trump uh has been very uh
uh uh very much opposed to
huawei being involved in 5g in the us
and has gotten
got many uh friends and allies in europe
and australia
uh new zealand uh to um to
shun huawei out of fear that they will
uh that their technology will be used to
spy on the
on the local population uh but
these companies like huawei are also
involved in
artificial intelligence facial
recognition in the singapore airport you
have facial recognition
and uh that's been been produced
by by i think it is huawei but chinese
firms like alibaba
tencent jd.com are also investing
billions in uh
in uh and startups like go check the uh
the um the motorcycle uber
kind of thing company uh it's broader
than that but
that's how it sort of started tokepedia
traveloka
and various china fintech chinese
fintech companies are also very active
in indonesia about two-thirds of
china's investment in the e-commerce and
the
digital spaces in in indonesia and
singapore
i guess that makes sense indonesia is
the biggest country with 160 170 million
people in singapore is by far the most
the wealthiest there's only two
countries that are shunning huawei and
that is
uh not surprisingly eric vietnam as you
probably know is not terribly
enthusiastic
uh and as of shunt uh huawei and
singapore
uh for for 5g is giving the
biggest uh contracts to ericsson and
nokia
but is giving huawei some minor roles um
that is yeah um the ethnic chinese
uh there are we don't know exactly how
many but probably about two percent of
southeast asia's population
is ethnic chinese many of them came over
the centuries
um including at the end of the qing
dynasty they came to
southeast asia off mostly in in search
of of
economic opportunities they came to
places like malaysia
to aid the british colonial effort
helped with rubber
and uh and palm and tin oil
tint and oil in tin um
mining um operations so they
but then they play started to play over
the years
uh much greater role in the economy so
they're they're
played played up quite a big role the
thing that really stunned me though was
the new migration which i don't think
beijing has
anything to do with but you're seeing
increasing numbers
of chinese come into southeast asia
the places where you see the most of
them are in in northern myanmar
north of mandalay and northern laos uh
where they are involved in plantations
uh rubber uh bananas watermelons
green beans uh pumpkins just an
awful lot of agricultural uh and
industrial agricultural products um
creating a lot of tensions in the region
because they use a lot of
chemical pesticides and chemical
fertilizer which is
polluting the rivers and causing
causing draft animals and
and uh to to diet uh
the um uh the then they also move into
some cities
uh there are quite a few obviously there
were a lot in cyanucville
uh in in cambodia especially
until the end of last year when when
china and
uh got hung-sen the prime minister of
cambodia to agree to
end online gaming and uh a lot of
casino gambling um but this there's also
a fair quite a large number of ethnic
chinese moving to manila
um and then uh the the uh the guys who
left
cyanucoville after the clampdown on on
gaming
uh they moved to to cayenne or karin
state in myanmar and they set up uh
casinos there
coco being one of the more famous ones
um so i i guess i'm a little bit
concerned that long term
uh the the the uh popul the ethnic
population
and in northern myanmar and northern
laos can have a huge
cultural and uh political impact in in
in those parts of of the of those two
countries in particular
that his the history of china was with
southeast asia obviously
goes back to for millennia uh
uh china once controlled northern
vietnam for
uh as a colonial power uh for almost uh
a thousand years uh but um
but after the communists took over in
1949 the communist party
set supported communist forces against
most of the governments that were all
establishing themselves after the end of
world war ii when many of them got
independence from their european
colonial masters
um and this this period when when they
shine when china was supporting domestic
communists
uh it still remains a legacy in many of
these countries today so
this is what what is one of the
challenges and for
jokowi and other leaders in indonesia
that many people still are convinced
that that china
was involved in a coup in which which
hundreds of thousands of people in the
end
got got killed uh and
there's a lot of fear uh that that china
may
may still be involved politically um
they're they're joki himself the first
time he ran for power
he uh and he was a mayor of solo a
little
little uh town
in in java he um he was accused of being
both a christian
and an ethnic chinese and he's uh he's
uh
pretty pretty clearly uh uh
uh indonesian the javanese uh who's a
muslim
but uh the people that that kind of
charging people with being chinese is is
uh
often a weapon you can use against them
and that's what happened to the the
mayor who replaced
jokowi and in jakarta he was uh ethnic
chinese
uh his nickname was a hawk he is um
he was ethnic chinese and a christian
and he got
nailed with uh allegations of of
blasphemy for uh when he tried to tell a
joke
uh uh and uh about muslims and
it did not go over very well at all um
opinion polls they're they're they're
tough to to
figure out how much how popular uh china
is
but um the uh they're
the institute for southeast asian
studies in singapore
um does annual surveys and
the january the survey that came out in
january these are elite
polls where they were they where they
asked
officials and academics and business
people and journalists and ngo people
um to to give their views
and the poll that came out in january
had
79 of southeast asians saying china was
had the most economic influence in the
region
about uh only eight percent and thought
that about the united states
but even more surprising was that 52
percent said china was the most
politically
and strategically influential in
southeast asia and only
27 percent about half thought that about
the united states
uh but if then if they were forced to
choose between china and the us which of
course southeast asia doesn't want to do
but 46 percent
chose china 54
chose the united states which is pretty
close actually
uh china has really stepped up military
to military ties
and in recent years it's it's sold some
arms
to some countries uh particularly
thailand
uh since the coup has purchased uh
the 2014 coup purchased some tanks
uh it ordered some submarines um
malaysia has had some coastal patrol
vessels purchased uh by
uh purchased from china uh
myanmar and uh and cambodia also get uh
quite a bit of military hardware from
china
um some countries like indonesia are
looking
occasionally look to buy more uh but
really uh in the end they they haven't
uh china is also stepping up its
military
exercises still way behind where the us
is in terms of uh frequency and size
uh they also offered to do some training
but that also of of uh southeast asian
officers and
chinese military schools but it's still
way behind what
what the us does um
china is really uh
very big in soft power uh
it it provides uh just oodles of
scholarships and i say oodles because
we it's really hard to get numbers on uh
total number
numbers for southeast asia but in in
2016
uh there were almost 70 000 southeast
asians studying
in china the by far the biggest number
was the ties
23 000 followed by indonesians 15
000 um
vietnam i think was 11 or 12 000 which
is still pretty high
uh china has also been very busy setting
up confucius
institutes which which provide
uh mandarin language training there's
about 30 now in the region half of them
15 are in thailand five in malaysia one
in indones
one in the philip two in the philippines
one in vietnam
uh and they're also inviting many more
people
to from southeast asia to come visit uh
this includes
party officials not only from communist
countries but also from malaysia and
indonesia
they invite party officials a pdip
which is a jokowi's party they
he sends his party sends
officials for training in terms of
about how do you do budgets how you
recruit new members that kind of stuff
it's not
not marxist leninist training
duterte president duterte of the
philippines has uh
what's its pl oh boy i'm forgetting the
name of his party right now the acronym
but his party also sends uh people to uh
uh party leaders to to china
uh lots of journalists lots of religious
leaders
they really are china since uh
since the treatment of the uyghurs and
xinjiang has become
more high-profile global a has invited a
lot of muslims
uh muslim leaders imams to visit
xinjiang
um and
um many of them come back very positive
speaking very positively so like a work
camp atmosphere
where they can pray five times a day
they can eat halal food etc
um some are so positive that the chinese
ambassador will visit has happened in
the case of one village in
in in java and in indonesia and uh
he did he offered to build them a new
irrigation
system thanks to the imam's very
positive
effusive uh description of how
the uyghurs are treated um
china i i've been i really worked hard
at trying to figure out
the level of chinese political influence
um you you do see some examples but
it's not nearly as obvious as it is in
australia or new zealand
uh in the 2018 elections in malaysia the
chinese ambassador
he actually went and campaigned for some
of the ruling party
officials the um no and and the chinese
the malaysian chinese association
officials they actually did quite poorly
and lost the election
and in in from about the mid
2016 to mid 2017 china
and singapore were at um china was in
the middle of
uh an isil let's isolate singapore
campaign
uh partially because the the prime
minister had been critic
had urged china to follow rule of law
in response to the uh un
arbitral tribunal uh that the
philippines had brought
ruling overwhelmingly in favor of the uh
of uh the philippines
uh china went ballistic
and started really singapore is the
biggest investor in
in uh china and really start putting
pressure
trying to put pressure on businessmen if
you want to keep operating here
uh you will have to um you will have to
get your government to change policy
which really
should i say really irritated the
singapore government
and they didn't really respond to the
businessman's lobby i guess
um china is also very active in
fishing and hacking and vietnam despite
the fact that it might be a
communist ally technically quote unquote
uh is get is off in the brunt of it
uh when vietnam was going to host the
apec the uh asia pacific economic
cooperation forum in 2017 that was going
to be attended by both she
and trump um china
hacked pretty pretty badly often you
they often use
fishing techniques where they get uh
officials to open open their open
certain software that then goes into
malware that goes into their computers
and they
they give a dump of their their uh their
negotiating strategy
the chinese also regularly look for
vietnam strategy
in the south china sea try to figure out
what the
higher what the party is saying about
that and then
ahead of the completion of the
negotiations for the regional
comprehensive economic partnership which
was just signed what about two or three
weeks ago
um the chinese also hacked
into vietnam system quite a bit uh
indonesian officials in 20 in the
elections in 2019 charged both the
chinese and russians with hacking into
their voter lists
um they the chinese hacked into
singh health where they downloaded just
reams of
documentation about the health uh
conditions of various singaporeans
including prime minister lee
um some some of that stuff
irritates those southeast asians quite a
bit but they say uh they point out that
china is not the only
big power that that's constantly spying
on them
which i won't name that other big power
you probably know where
where you're sitting um and i'll
conclude with some comments on
water i'm actually realized i'm going a
lot longer than i thought
um uh one of the concerns is what's
happening in this
in the uh in the on the mekong
uh china has built 11 dams in the upper
reaches of the mekong
and then has helped build dams along the
mekong
as we come through laos thailand
cambodia
and into into vietnam um
uh china the water from
china contributes about 25 or so percent
of the water in the mekong uh and
the mekong is about
in southeast asia in in laos thailand
myanmar indian
vietnam would 60 million people make
their living along that fishing and
farming uh the the uh
mekong is one of the the most fertile
fishing uh sources in the world
and one of the the biggest uh
uh spawning areas for fish
along the mekong is the tony sap
uh which is the lake in the middle of
cambodia that
during rainy season explodes as a as a
tributary of the mekong
uh carries water up into the tonle sap
and kerry brings a lot of fish with it
and
then in dry season the water flows back
down
and moves the fish back into the mekong
main tributary and in in
in the vietnam's mekong delta the level
of water
matters a lot because it is the mekong
delta
is the breadbasket of vietnam
it is also uh below sea level
so if it doesn't get water from the
mekong and silt all the way from tibet
uh it can slip into the sea and so
what's happened the last two years as
china has
opened up its um it's uh
really started running its its 11 dams
the dam uh number seven and damn number
eleven
they those two uh hold enough water
to fill the chesapeake bay uh
just not terribly far from where you
guys or i am sitting right now
and um this has caused a lot of
because of water being rain being
less this the last few years than it had
been earlier
uh has caused severe drought and so we
are uh the agricultural uh crops are
being damaged the
uh the um spawning uh
fish is is being hurt and the mekong
delta in
vietnam is being hurt so um i
um so that this has become a huge issue
and
the the mekong countries have started to
press china on this but so far
china has has only said they first of
all they start by saying they also
faced the drought we now know that they
didn't in fact
because a group called eyes on the earth
took satellite photos early this year
and earlier this year about six or eight
months ago
and found massive the massive quantities
of water that i was referring to
and uh so they the aseans
uh started push putting a lot of
pressure on china
china has agreed to start giving them
data on how much water they're holding
uh we'll have to see if if if
the countries of of laos thailand uh
cambodia and vietnam can exert more
pressure so that china will be
more um more accommodating
i don't know uh um
if i should eric should i talk a little
bit about the south china sea or do you
think most people here know about the
south china sea and we can leave it for
question and answer because
i realize we have about 20 minutes left
[Music]
i i'd say that if you just mention it
briefly and then
wrap it to a close then we'll have time
and we can linger a little bit beyond
the hour if you have time but that's
up to you um some people will leave
right at the hour but i'm i'm happy to
stick around too
okay well so i'll i'll try to go over
the south china sea um
very quickly i think that is something
that is covered more in the news and the
us government talks about it
but uh the south china sea and this is
maybe you asked me or
was going to use a map maybe it would
have been useful uh to have a map of
this but
the south china sea has a big u-shaped
line uh dotted line in it nine dotted
line
which is china's claims to about eighty
percent of the south china sea
it claims uh all the fish and the
uh seafood and the hydrocarbons in that
area uh which is
also where uh vietnam philippines and
malaysia
and to some extent indonesia which
actually isn't a claimant the claimant
countries
disputing with china are vietnam
malaysia philippines and brunei
but part of the nine dash line runs
through northern natuna
uh which is in the far north western
part of of indonesia um
in 2009 uh country china's interest in
the south china sea is relatively
recent in 2009 uh countries
based on the u.n conventional obviously
that was a deadline for countries to put
in their claims
southeast the main southeast asian
countries put in their claims china was
really irritated
at how much of their claims uh
overlapped without those of china
uh in 2012 uh china took
um took uh scarborough shoal from the
philippines
uh and a pretty dramatic move
uh the philippines brought the case that
i referred to earlier
uh and uh in 2013
2016 the uh arbitral tribunal ruled
against
china 26 2016 or 2015. boy both dates
stick in my head now but um
ruled against china and uh china was abs
went went ballistic uh ignored the
ruling totally
it had earlier as soon as the
philippines brought the case started
building building artificial islands
in the south china sea um
built seven built up seven islands by
dredging uh
sand and uh grinding up coral which
is pretty bad because coral is a natural
habitat for seafood
uh uh four of the islands have now have
military
uh landing strips so military planes and
radar and missile installations have
been installed
it is now possible for china to fly from
these bases to any capital
in southeast asia
two years ago china really did ramp up
its
pressure again and tried to press
vietnam and malaysia and the philippines
to abandon some of their efforts
to look for oil and gas
they started harassing uh chinese uh
big chinese coast guard vessels and and
um
maritime militia vessels uh began
harassing exploration activities
and um uh really
made it clear i think to southeast asia
their southeast asian competitors that
you really
uh should stop trying to develop these
these hydrocarbons uh off your coasts
with
foreign companies like shell and rosneff
and repso
real estate being russian repsol being
spanish
uh and either either do it with us
or do it by yourself none of them can do
it by themselves
so it's really created problems
especially for vietnam
and the philippines in terms of wanting
to
develop gas resources for for
uh uh making it possible for them to
fire
more hydro high fire more power
using gas rather than dirty coal burning
technology that they have all gotten
from china and
in the case of malaysia which is the
second largest exporter of
uh oil and gas it is a major source of
government revenue
but a quarter of the government's
revenue comes from this
and so what doesn't quite know how this
is all going to be resolved but there is
a lot of tension
uh on uh between these countries
uh the us regularly sails through there
with
so-called freedom of navigation
exercises which tells them
which is intended to tell the chinese we
don't accept your claims
uh sometimes other countries
have have joined the us uh earlier this
year
both australia and japan went along for
the for a for a short
uh sail through by by american vessels
um this is the one area though where
where the the us hasn't has been
relatively quiet
but under under trump uh and beginning
in august
uh secretary of state pompeo began very
sharply criticizing the chinese
it was part of a whole anti-china
campaign that you might have known
deals with taiwan it deals with hong
kong it deals with the uyghurs
in xinjiang it deals with huawei
it puts tariffs on various forms of
chinese trade
because their us is frustrated at
chinese stealing intellectual property
rights and forcing u.s companies to do
technology transfer and those kinds of
things so
the the the water both the mekong
and the and the uh south china sea are
two areas where it is quite possible for
for accidents and that could lead into
to more conflict
and is the one area in which china has a
bit
has a quite a black eye in especially
the
the maritime southeast asian countries
so i'm going to stop there eric and let
you turn to questions
sorry that went a little longer than i
intended to
murray no need to apologize there's a
lot to talk about um
and you gave a really comprehensive
coverage of
so many issues with china's investment
and interactions with southeast asia so
let's open it up to
questions at this point um anyone who
has a question
um if you can use the in the
participants
tab of zoom there is a function to raise
your hand
that's the easiest way to do it and if
you can't
find that just send a message to the
chat
and i'll note your name and we already
have two hands up we'll start with john
mitcheller i believe it is and after
that will be greg miller
thanks very much can you all hear me yes
we can
uh excellent presentation thank you for
your time today i have a quick question
uh related to the belt road initiative
particularly in southeast asia
do you feel uh if that
the conditions could be created to make
the belt road a an enabling condition
for sustainability you know building
linear infrastructure
railroads roads
high tension wires you name it i mean
all of that comes with an ecological
cost
but there's a lot of science out there
on how to do that stuff more sustainably
and i'm just wondering in your opinion
do you think there's
there is room for dialogue with china to
talk about how to do that in a green way
that actually makes it a win-win
situation
for all parties involved or is it really
just
about getting it done the cheapest way
to make money for
china um and hope for the best for the
other countries i mean do you have any
opinion on that because i'd like to i'd
like to think that there was some
some hope and optimism for the former
i i think there's hope uh it'll take
some time you may
recall that at the end of last year uh
xi jinping
uh hosted a a conference
with main recipients of the belton road
in in beijing i think it was in november
and he did in his speech acknowledge
that china needed to be more green in
its projects and less corrupt
in his projects which you know i think
that was a
a good um a good start um
and then you might have seen i'm trying
to remember what the name of the group
was there was a european group
uh this week uh i read this in the
financial times i think did uh did a
report
uh making exactly suggestions like you
had like you just did
suggesting that there would be uh
various
uh that there should be various ways to
do a lot of these things
in a greener way um i think what it
would require
is um uh countries in the region
also saying we just have to have greener
projects
uh we you know the the the uh dams that
china built not only in china but also
several in in in
laos and in cambodia uh just really
are ecologically very devastating and
harmful
but i think you you also have the
benefit of
of china back home facing a lot of
pressure from environment just the
population
getting tired of having dirty air dirty
water
um and wanting more uh more
environmentally
sound projects and it's interesting that
china now is
only exporting it's really its worst
coal-fired
project uh plants to to
neighboring countries they no longer can
get away with doing this at home
so i think if if if some of the tensions
were brought down a little bit that
maybe
the us and china could could get back on
the same page on
uh sort of on the same page under paris
the paris
climate agreement i think there would be
ways to
press china uh at international at the
highest international levels but then
also working with countries
you know laos for example they they're
now trying to build one more
dam on the on the on the mekong and
you know i don't know where they get off
on these things these things cost two
billion dollars they have to repay this
and i didn't even go into the story
where
the electricity uh distribution
company laos in september had to turn
over uh it's it's because of their
uh because of its massive debt to the
chinese
had to allow china southern power to
take over their power
their power grid which is just
unbelievable
and i can't believe that the
international community
the imf offered other solutions but they
did
in the end they just did this but i i
they went with the chinese but i can't
believe that
that thailand and vietnam um among
others wouldn't have just said no we're
not doing this we'll
figure out ways to bail you out but then
they want to build another dam when
when on the which the thais are already
saying we're not gonna
that that's the other thing you can get
country neighboring countries to put
pressure on so
the ties after a damn burst
uh in southern laos two years ago
unfortunately it wasn't built by the
chinese it was built by the south
koreans
we needed that lever but we didn't get
it um
um the thais the thai population is
saying we no longer want
hydro power electricity laos has lots of
land lots of mountains
lots of wind lots of sun why don't we
the solar is going down
the cost of solar is going down the cost
of winds going down why don't we just
introduce that stuff
and we will buy your power and i think
if we put pressure on countries like
laos and put pressure on the chinese
internationally and
and in the region i think you could get
quite a bit of traction to move ahead
but it would need a lot of persistence
and coordination i think
yeah good question thank you murray i'm
going to turn it over to gregory miller
who has the next question
thank you uh back in 2017 after the apec
meeting
uh compass and jakarta ran a front page
story trump versus zz wins
and from what you've said it sounds like
that hasn't changed very much
nor did the trump administration seem to
care
should the u.s care and what advice
whether we should or shouldn't what
advice would you give
to the biden administration uh
on u.s in to enhance u.s influence
in southeast asia yeah
um well you know it's it's gonna it's a
little hard to make recommendations when
you know that
that biden's first priorities have to be
to get control of covet and
get this economy going again right for
so many that are just locked
out um uh thanks to kovat
and the shutdown that related from it um
yeah there
the southeast asia really does want the
us
to play a more active role and when when
the us
uh when congress passed the so-called
build act about what two or three years
ago
60 billion dollars and then
set up this thing called they turned the
old opec
into something called the development
finance corp
uh which obviously doesn't have a lot of
money is around 60 billion but it's at
least a start
and they're they're able to do joint
ventures
with other countries like the japanese
or aussies let's say
uh they're also able to do joint
ventures with private companies
uh so that might might be uh might be a
possible way to get involved
they were really bothered when the u.s
pulled out of the transfers when trump
pulled out of the trans-pacific
partnership
it it's not like that was going to be
the mother of all
all platforms to trade on but it showed
the us was involved and it provided to
vietnam
and malaysia at least some alternatives
to just depending so heavily on on
on china uh they would have they were
very disappointed trump only showed up
at one
east asia summit meeting this is
something that follows immediately after
the asean
and the the autumn uh the november asean
meeting uh of leaders they do have the
east asia summit trump showed up once
actually only in manila he gave a speech
and left before the meeting actually
started so they they remember this stuff
for southeast asians you know you
show you're interested by showing up
and the trump guys they didn't show up
this year
again but that was after the election
but they sent
to the uh asean summit and to the east
asia summit they sent o'brien the head
of the national security council an
unconfirmed member of the
the trump team which you know is not the
highest level
um the year before they sent him and uh
what's his name um uh uh uh
ross that the secretary of of commerce
who also isn't the most dynamic
secretary in uh trump's cabinet
you know they um so they really
uh uh the the the trump team has
really uh not shown southeast asia that
except for the pentagon the pentagon
under mattis initially but continuing
has showed up it did a lot of exercises
it did a lot of training it kept
kept going with um with uh
you know the the the exercises that have
been going on
for for for decades um
and you know try to be helpful
to countries like vietnam malaysia
indonesia philippines that have been
wanting to
uh that need that really don't have the
wherewithal to
see what china is doing in the south
china sea so
the the uh beginning under the
last few years of the obama
administration the military start
providing them with more
military and maritime domain awareness
radar small boats uh
25 30 foot vessels that they could use
to
try to figure out what the chinese were
up to um
so i think they need to get more
involved economically and if they could
get involved in some
some infrastructure that would be good
if they could and they
are they've just bid on the us companies
on you
through this vehicle the dfc have have
been bidding on some projects in myanmar
on
on on on renewable energy
um but they've got to they've gone gonna
have to be more active
and and the one thing that the southeast
asians don't want is an all-out
war hot war but even a cold war between
china and southeast asia because they
they provide
so much input to the global supply chain
right
so apple apple iphones or
or a lot of the computers are assembled
in china using
technology from all over southeast asia
so
they would not like to see that either
but yeah get involved and i think
biden's people the people he's putting
in the
white house uh and in the uh and
in the state department is assuming they
get confirmed
are people that are more engagers then
than
they the guys who were under the trump
thank you thanks murray um
we have uh one more question from daniel
lonto uh yanto sorry about that
um before we turn to that i should note
that it is one o'clock those of you who
needed to leave it one you're free to do
so but we will keep the conversation
going for
another 10 15 minutes i i have time for
that
and i i hope you do as well murray do
you have time to stay for an extra
15 minutes yes okay great go ahead
daniel
hi murray i i really do appreciate the
country by country analysis i thought it
was really fascinating
um however you've been briefly
mentioning asean and i'm curious to what
extent
asean countries sort of as a collective
unit
have been able to influence china in the
region
yeah that is another whole topic we i
should maybe have gone into
um so
um one thing that that has really hurt
uh asean's ability to stand up to china
is that you need to have unanimity
within the grouping
before you can issue
a communiques for example so
beginning in 2012 you might recall that
uh
there was a that was the year that china
had taken scarborough shoal from the
philippines
uh asean tried to issue a statement
and cambodia uh was hosting
asean that year and cambodia by far
is the um the the country closest to
uh to china and they had chinese
officials
uh in the in the in some of the uh
visiting rooms close to
where the meeting was happening and that
uh hor nam hong who was then the foreign
minister
probably one of ben's favorite friends
or come on not kidding
but um he he would constantly go check
with the chinese and in the end they
couldn't come up with a
with a a resolution and
uh that really has hurt
uh the aseans a lot
um almost every year uh there's an
effort at
uh bringing uh some some uh
you know just joint statement to
criticize
china for its behavior and they can't do
it because of china's ability to split
off
almost alway always cambodia and quite
often laos
and quite often myanmar now the thing
that's going to be interesting
is what's going to happen in the mekong
this thing has really been heating up
for
most of 2020 and
vietnam tried to uh i understand from
vietnamese diplomats that they tried to
bring up raise this issue
in asean thinking that maybe they would
get more support from countries like
cambodia laos
and even thailand that doesn't care much
about the south china sea because it
isn't a disputing country
um but it really didn't work
but it's really interesting there is
something called
see if i can recreate it now i don't use
this word every this
this acronym every day but there is uh
there is a
u.n convention on
non-non-inevitable uses of rivers or
something like that i don't know exactly
what it's called
but there are 18 uh countries
in asia not only southeast asia that
for whom the source of their river
begins in
in china and if countries that are
losing uh water because of
because of china's taking it
keeping it storing it uh would all
gang up maybe it's the right word maybe
if they'd all cooperate
and put pressure on china not only a
couple little countries in southeast
asia but also
central asia south asia you might be
able
to uh get china to
to recognize yeah it's it's china says
we have
if it begins with our country we have
rights of first use you know that's your
problem if you're further down
um but uh you know i think
china if it wants to be a global player
is going to probably have to learn how
to share its
toys in the sandbox and uh
uh you know i i think that that
that the mekong does open up a whole new
uh opportunity for for
getting countries like cambodia if if
cambodian farmers
so china against cambodia and laos all
this aid right
um but if the cost to their farmers
in in rice and fish is far
more than what they get from china and
aid are they going to want to keep doing
this
uh it doesn't make any sense so let's
see what happens but
but asean you know because it's uh
based on consensus has a lot of trouble
um
putting a lot of pressure on countries
unless they can
everybody agrees thank you for that
great our next question is from david
lindsay
yes am i unmuted yes can you
yes thank you very much for this talk
it's fascinating
and i want to ask you about um
something i heard from a scholar on
vietnam
in this same lecture series a few years
ago
he reported that many chinese vessels
were sinking vietnamese fishing boats
was 2018 or 19. and
he said that the problem was that the
vietnamese government the higher levels
were now basically on the chinese
government payroll
they had been bought out and so they
were not raising a fuss about this
and that it was there were there were
actually um
demonstrations in the streets by
fishermen and their friends
and and patriots but that the chinese
government was was
turning a blind eye could you comment on
whether there's some truth to this
story or not um
so vietnamese fishermen
you know there are two big groupings of
islands in the south china sea the
northern one is the paracels
uh where which the chinese took
from the vietnamese in 1974 you might
remember in 1974
uh the u.s backed south vietnamese
government was still in power
and they took it from that government
the us let them do it
um because they were in the middle of
normalizing relations
uh but now you know it's it's really too
late the chinese have now controlled it
for years
so but a lot of fishermen vietnamese
fishermen from
central and northern vietnam go there
and
uh they are regularly arrested some
boats are burnt
some are sunk uh yes uh they also sink
boats of the filipinos off
and and indonesians off their coasts
um every year uh china
so china puts in force a moratorium that
that divides the south china sea and any
fishing north of that line is banned
it's at the 35th
parallel i think if i recall um
and and so they they do detain
uh more detain and then release after a
while
fishermen but there are some thinking
that's for sure
now domestically vietnam has
the hanoi has a really interesting uh
situation
in 2018 vietnam in the middle of the
year vietnam
the the national assembly of vietnam
tried to pass
a law on on special economic zones
that law didn't mention china once um
but the population assumed that chinese
companies were going to get access to
land
and the the law said that a company that
invests
could keep get to keep the land for 99
years well vietnamese farmers can only
keep their land for 50 years and then
they have to renegotiate and all that
stuff
um so the population went crazy
and uh really did have huge protests
both in hanoi and in the south
uh and in central vietnam some of them
turned violent and uh
at uh taiwanese uh steel mill in
central uh north central vietnam
in taining
attacked the steel mill that was being
built by chinese workers for this
taiwanese company
and two or three or so chinese actually
died in the in the process um
the government recognizes
fully that it has it's on a very short
leash by the population
uh in 19 let me see now
1997 the government
gave uh gypsum mine in central vietnam
to to uh the chinese
and even general wagons up the general
who was then who helped win the war for
the vietnamese communists
he um he wrote a letter protesting the
uh the uh the the giving the chinese
access to this
this this mine in central vietnam
and in the highlands central highlands
uh
there is yeah and then you have uh uh
academics uh uh
you know a lot of um artists
a lot of people protest almost anything
that
that the vietnamese government does are
is the government sold out to china um
no uh they are standing up to china
a lot um uh
sometimes they capitulate but the
vietnamese i
i i i got quite a bit of access in doing
this book to
uh com party officials and
they uh uh said that in
in 2018
when china was putting a lot of pressure
on
this spanish oil company called repsol
there was uh the these polyp bureau
voted
trying to remember the public bureau is
was 17
is it do you remember eric is the pub
you're 17 or 19 now they've
increased the numbers i can't remember
but it's somewhere either 17 or 19.
two officials voted to abandon the
project with repsol
which cost the vietnamese 500 million
dollars they owed repso
around 500 million dollars neither side
has said exactly but
but some economists have calculated it
have cost them that much
um the the party chief and the
ahead of the military voted to abandon
the project the rest of the politburo
voted to stay there
stand their ground but they the the two
leaders did win in that case and they
abandoned the project however
when china repeated this pressure last
year the
vietnamese no longer had a spanish
company
they had repsol which is a vladimir
putin company
stayed on enterprise and they don't they
don't stand down
easily for anybody as you would guess
and they didn't
they didn't leave and in the end the
chinese just sort of wore
out and and left um
it's a very complicated issue but to say
that vietnam
vietnam is taking no belt and road money
uh china has included a very disastrous
project in it that started actually well
before the belton road it's
it's the uh it's the sky train in
in hanoi which has been built under
construction for 10 years the price
keeps going up and it's never going to
be finished i guess
um if you're cynical but
uh
they're the vietnamese are doing the
best they can
i would say to stand up to china without
going to war which they know they can't
afford
um i don't know if that answers your
question it's i know it's rambling but
it's a very complicated issue in vietnam
no that's great thank you i'll just add
murray i think i think you were
definitely right on the money with your
answer there um
also with the recent politburo chain it
was 2016 and i think it's actually the
12th politburo
um but um there was a shuffling and i
think
some of the the consolidation of a of
power that occurred
used uh claims of the previous uh
prime minister um claiming that he was
in the pocket of the chinese whether he
really was or not is a very complicated
thing to figure out to be honest
um but they certainly mobilize claims
about that in justification to remove
him
and the current mem current leadership
um would certainly uh portray itself as
strong against china we have one last
question um from i think it was
anita ngai was it um anita did you want
me to read your question that you had
posted or did you want to read it out
loud yourself
or are you even still here
anita are you there
she said please go ahead all right
please go ahead i missed the
chat disappear so i'll i'll read it um
and you can see it yourself as well
murray but i'll read it quickly
chinese fdi into the us has dropped a
lot how has the trend been
into southeast asia one key sector for
the fdi
is tech and there's a list of tech
companies
and then with tension high between
australia and china has australia been
stepping up their involvement with asean
affairs
given the time that we have you can
either answer both of them
quickly or briefly
or one of them yeah um
well this year uh obviously
uh chinese investment has been hammered
just because it's so hard to
travel that there's no
chinese are going in and out
so it will be reduced but this year but
i think
generally i would it would i would say
chinese investment has really started to
take off
it has it was slow for a long time but
it's really started to take off
at the belton road maybe it started
started very high it's maybe
going down but general investment
including in technology i as you said
and
uh uh and as i noted uh is still
is still really going up australia it
you know it's too early to to really
have
seen uh australia investment go up as a
result of
the um the uh wolf warriors going after
after australia but australia has been
over the last oh two or three years
getting much more active in southeast
asia cooperating with japan
uh and others to play a bigger role in
southeast asia which is
as a middle power south southeast asia
really appreciates australia's role
thank you murray um with that i think
we're at the end of our
a lot of time i i want to thank you for
such a fascinating
discussion today obviously you've opened
so many doorways to further
investigation as well and i i hope that
this topic we can keep revisiting during
this series
um i also it occurred to me that it
would be very interesting sometime in
the future to organize
uh just a panel discussion perhaps with
you and nyan chanda
about the history of the far eastern
economic review or
to hear about the the time of your
journalism
which was such an important time in
developing on the ground knowledge about
southeast asia
but we'll leave that for another time um
i'll linger
and tell people a sign off
and leave the the chat open for a couple
more minutes but i just wanted to thank
you
formally and i'll press stop on the
recording right now